NIGHT FOR LIVE UPDATES ON
TROPICAL STORM BARRY.
♪♪ ♪♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL
EDITION OF HANNITY, THE RUSSIA
BROOM RANG.
WE HAVE A STUDIO AUDIENCE FULL
OF EXPERTS WHO WILL BREAK DOWN
THE SWINGING PENDULUM OF JUSTICE
TWO.
-PLUS YEARS, DEMOCRATS, THE DEEP
STATE, THE MEDIA MOB ALL WORKING
TOGETHER, WHAT FIRST TO STOP ONE
PERSON, BECOMING PRESIDENT.
THEN TAKE DOWN A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WITH CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND A
RUSSIAN HOAX.
TONIGHT THE PRESIDENT REMAINS
UNSCATHED.
THOSE WHO ABUSE THEIR POWER,
THOSE INVOLVED IN CORRUPTION,
WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS DOES INCLUDE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
WE EXPECT HE WILL APPEAR ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR A PUBLIC
HEARING AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR POINTED OUT, DEMOCRATS ARE
HOPING TO TURN THE TESTIMONY
INTO A SPECTACLE.
FOR NADLER, THE COWARDLY SHIFT,
ONE MORE EXCUSE TO TRY AND SMEAR
TRUMP.
FOR REPUBLICANS, THIS HEARING IS
A GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE ASKED,
TO ROBERT MUELLER.
HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE ANSWERS TO ALL.
PRESSING QUESTIONS THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS TOTALLY IGNORED
AND THE MEDIA MOB IGNORED.
MUELLER MUST ANSWER, WHY DID HE
HIRE A TEAM FULL OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS, NOT ONE REPUBLICAN
AVAILABLE.
?
WHY WOULD HE HIRE IN THIS CASE
HILLARY CLINTON'S FORMER
ATTORNEY?
WHY DID HE HIRE THIS GIESHGS
ANDREW WEISSMANN?
GUY WHO WITHHELD EXCULPATORY IN
EVIDENCE THE PAST,
CLINTON-LOVING PARTISAN HACK, HE
WAS THERE THE NIGHT OF CLINTON'S
VICTORY PARTY THAT NEVER
HAPPENED.
A RECORD FULL OF PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT.
WHY DID MUELLER HAVE TIME
INVESTIGATE LOAN APPLICATIONS,
FARA VIOLATIONS, TAX FRAUD.
BUT HE DIDN'T LOOK AT THE DIRTY
DOSSIER, LYING TO A FISA COURT,
THE PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTED
ON A COURT TO SPY ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN?
WHY WAS THE PROBE NEVER IN TO
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES.
WHAT ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
WITH HIS RUSSIAN LIES.
WHAT ABOUT GLEN SIMPSON, FUSION
GPS, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
COORDINATION WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OF UKRAINE THAT WE HAVE POINTED
OUT.
KEEP IN MIND PEOPLE LIKE MICHAEL
COHEN, PAUL MANAFORT, MICHAEL
FLYNN, GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS,
CHARGED WITH CRIMES TOTALLY
UNRELATED TO COLLUSION,
CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA TO IMPACT
THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
IN AN INVESTIGATION SUPPOSEDLY
ABOUT COLLUSION AND CORRUPTION,
NO ONE CONNECTED TO CLINTON, THE
DNC, THEIR PHONY RUSSIAN SOURCED
OP RESEARCH, HOW DID YOU IGNORE
THAT, MR. MUELLER?
DOES ROBERT MUELLER HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
DID HE HIRE PEOPLE THAT HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR A REASON,
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP.
THIS WHY HE PURSUED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO CONSTRUCTION
EVEN AFTER THERE WAS NO
UNDERLYING CRIME OF CONSPIRACY
OR COLLUSION?
WHY IS MUELLER GIVEN
CONTRADICTORY STATEMENTS ON THE
TOPIC OF OBSTRUCTION.
IS HE BEING PRESSURED BY ANDREW
WEISSMANN?
DID HE FORGET?
DID HE NOT REMEMBER WHAT HE
SAID?
DID HE WRITE THAT 9 1/2 MINUTE
RAMBLING PRESS CONFERENCE?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IS ROB
MUELLER REALLY PROUD OF HIS 22
MONTH WITCH HUNT, THAT REALLY
DID NOTHING THAN GIVE FUEL TO
WHAT ARE RAMPANT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIES, MISINFORMATION.
A WHOLE CHANNEL CONSPIRACY
CHANNEL, MSDNC, OR MAKE NEWS
CNN.
NO PRESIDENT SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
FACE THIS KIND OF FLAWED,
PARTISAN, PHONY,
CONSPIRACY-ORIENTED
INVESTIGATION EVER AGAIN.
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
THANKFULLY TONIGHT THE BOOMERANG
OF JUSTICE IS IN FULL SWING.
WE HAVE SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO FISA ABUSE, DEEP STATE
MISCONDUCT, CORRUPTION AND LIKES
AND THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIAN
PROBE WELL UNDER WAY.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS THE
HOROWITZ INVESTIGATION INTO FISA
ABUSE IS NEARLY DONE UNTIL 191ED
HOUR.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE FINALLY
AGREED TO BE INTERVIEWED.
THE FORMER MI6 AGENT, AUTHOR OF
HILLARY'S DIRTY DOSSIER, GRILLED
FOR NEARLY 16 HOURS OVER THE
COURSE TWOCH DAYS IN GREAT
BRITAIN.
SOME SPECULATION THAT STEELE WAS
WORRIED THAT HIGH-RANKING U.S.
OFFICIALS WERE READY TO THROW
HIM UNDER THE BUS.
AND STEELE PROBABLY WANTED TO
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT ABOUT
HOW HIS DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
THAT CLINTON PAID FOR WAS
CREATED AND UTILIZED IN THE LEAD
UP TO THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
THIS IS LIKELY VERY BAD NEWS FOR
PEOPLE NAMES YOU KNOW WELL.
JIM COMEY, ANDREW McCABE,
STRZOK, PAIGE, BAKER, SO MANY
OTHERS, PEOPLE USING STEELE'S
UNVERIFIED AND FRANKLY
UNVERIFIABLE RUSSIAN GARBAGE TO
THEN SPY ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE, DONALD TRUMP, HIS
CAMPAIGN.
THEN IT BECAME THE TRUMP
TRANSITION TEAM.
EVEN THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
WE KNOW EVERYBODY WAS WARNED.
NONE OF IT IS VERIFIED.
THEY USED IT IN A PREMEDITATED
WAY TO CREATE A MASSIVE FRAUD ON
A FISA COURT, NOT ONCE BUT THREE